I'm going off the rails again I'm taking
a lot of pills and losing a lot of
friends need to manipulate salmon rent
to feel like they're happy that there's
no worries I can be goofy they can be
funny
I promised myself I would never shoot
another lightsaber video ever since
doing a lightsaber fight metal Star Wars
video I've made back in high school it's
been a long time you know why there was
an idea that I really liked and that was
this one about a lightsaber that grows
forever I was just really funny it was
cute it was the perfect corridor video
it's like classic classic corridor help
I might even say classic Freddy W I
really like the idea I want to make it
into a video i sat down I wrote up just
a little script and it's perfect and the
reason this video is perfect is because
all you need is a couple of friends a
lightsaber prop and that's it
easiest video to shoot don't need a
bunch of costumes you don't need a bunch
of locations it is the perfect internet
video
yeah I don't think it's gonna help so
come on nudes
not really not really there is no good
time this week so Sam and rain are
working in the anime self-driving car
video and it's a ton of work and they're
behind schedule
Sam's kind of stressed out Ren's kind of
stressed out I have to convince these
guys to cop stares forget all their
troubles and their worries
kuna Matata guys and then just relax and
fill up on you skin but yeah like when I
applied the so being a director is
partially about manipulating people it
sounds super you don't want to say that
but it is neat to manipulate the salmon
red to feel like they're happy that
there's no worries they can be goofy
they can be funny so I need to create
this fantasy land or they can just goof
around and run some bits and like feel
expressive you know included and all
that kind of stuff
rehearsing
and it's able to start rolling you know
it's going to take 20 minutes when they
have the entire first three or four
pages and your sole thing about two
hours yeah do I have three hours that
works for me three two one
dude what a letdown
three chatter whoo it's that something
that's it you gonna feel some fruit with
that how are you not impressed it's a
real light saber
I just got some bugs to figure out so
you might standing over there you toss
the box throw in cuts it then we get out
of here remove room so let's go and do
that okay so we're pretty much in the
rap video
we're like what are we gonna make this
about we were like oh let's shoot a
wizard rap video and we talked about
that but there you go drum roll please
Google autofill rap were you like start
the line and then you have you're forced
to rap about whatever the heck it's
supposed to say afterwards so you type
in the beginning of the line to like it
just into Google and you see what like
the suggestion that's how you tell the
story so then each is a rap video which
is probably not gonna run but most
rattles on your behind anyways all right
so it's like a very stereotypical like
generic rap like yo yo yo mama jokes
your mom come back imagine you're the
poor kid who searches for your mom
comebacks check this up if you just add
a space to everything so let's just say
we're done use juice juice in sign
language alright and but now I'm gonna
enter it and I get hit space juice and
baby video baby monitor
oh wait cuz here's the thing because it
knows what you were just searching for
video baby monitor Walmart
just like an incoherent rambling
rattling off the rails dude crazy trails
again I'm taking a lot of pills and lose
a lot of friends a lot of friends in
Spanish juice and sign language baby go
on like going off the rails on the crazy
train taking a lot of pills and losing a
lot of friends what do you say after
that how would you start a sentence
after that taking a lot of friends
Spanish what happens when you type gonna
gonna hold on friends in Spanish that's
where we are
[Music]
Jimmy Neutron just don't don't select
anything just I've been gonna gonna okay
look at all these good looks gonna make
you sweat gonna make you sweat I mean
these are all hilarious no I'm just
letting it flow dude I'm creating a flow
here Magic Mountain tickets is the
perfect internet video the hardest thing
I've found so far is the game with the
screwdriver at the very beginning it's
like I put this on and then I'm supposed
to screw it in but the problem is I keep
like missing the screw and it's the
close-up so it's a little embarrassing
so I sit down with Jake and he tells me
that it doesn't feel like a classic
corridor video it doesn't feel like
corridor at all to him it feels cheap
feels like we're just trying to get
something out there real quick and just
rush it and ask how can it not feel like
a corridor video when I'm the one
writing it like I defined corridor
corridor was me and say I'm making the
videos we want to make so to me like if
it's a video I want to make and it's a
corridor video and it doesn't matter we
just did a Star Wars thing that was very
similar to this and he wants to shoot it
in a style that I personally don't think
is going to have the greatest impact
maybe it's because I plan on shooting
the whole thing on the cell phone the
reason for this is I wanted to feel like
it's just a couple of dudes hanging out
having fun I don't want to feel like
it's presented I wanted to feel like
it's reality I am unsure but you know
what in this field I have to defer to
his expertise thing as a cell phone it's
light and it moves a certain way nothing
looks like a cell phone but a cell phone
Renne now telling me too that he doesn't
think the effects are gonna work very
well you know you have rolling shutter
and all kind of stuff but I think I'm
going to strive to prove them both wrong
and action
[Laughter]
yeah well Danny tell him we're taking a
break from that idea we kind of got into
the weeds and didn't know how to get out
Sam's got another idea he's been working
on we're gonna talk about it right now
what if the matrix was a janky early
access game these guys bought this early
access copy the matrix name what is it
what is it what is it it's like oh wow
these are my controllers for that new
game like what new game that's called
the matrix things like what's the matrix
like you've never heard of the matrix
the first open-world vr RPG designed
completely by robots and so they're
putting the controllers to their laptop
and they're like alright next and they
hold up these long-ass Burroughs needles
and they're like oh you mean like what
is like now like okay and they turn on
they already all have slots on their
necks ready to go they go into the
matrix they're like what do we do it's
the game about in there like you just do
whatever you want and they're like
really learn karate and float around and
[ __ ] and jump off stuff and like they go
to a nightclub and it's full of like
short Ugandan knuckles and [ __ ] like
dancing like here we go let's do it and
they start like downloading karate into
their brains and then windows pops up
with an update and like the computer
freezes and crashes like they died India
when you die in the matrix you dying
realize that's right end of the video
that's a good punch line there in the
training program remember they're in the
matrix everything freezes and they're
like what the [ __ ] going on you think
it's like a cool move they're doing you
know like one guy's like mid jump kick
just like frozen literally is going on
mom reset the modem
[Laughter]
yeah another one another really cool gag
is you know these photo scans we've been
doing here a scene where like things are
aren't loading in right and what you do
is you do a rough photo scan of the
environment we can reconstruct it low
quality and then we can read 3d track
that back into a real-life environment
so we can have it look like things are
like legit loading in you know the
sections pop in that would be a really
really cool effect just cubes things
that look really obvious basic things
that you should try to get into a car
and drive somewhere and it's like
driving ability has not been added to
the game yet because then like what if
there was a 12 year old in the game
would he look like a 12 year old they're
all just matrix I know you super market
like the cashiers wearing the same
glasses and let's uh put that baby they
haven't modeled babies yet it's just a
small so the shoot went well still
sensing some doubt as to my shooting on
a cell phone idea frankly once the
effects are in there it's kind of really
nice five
[Music]
give me some wild lines further people
screaming on the planet turns out at the
end of the day my biggest enemy was just
my own fears all I need to do is trust
myself and my friends ok well at the end
last year I made a little video talking
about my album that I was working at and
I said it's gonna be really soon guess
what I'm really singing right now you're
the music for free it's on YouTube it's
on Spotify take a look it's at
youtube.com slash Sam Gorski if you
liked it leave a comment if you don't
like it tell me why I'd like to get
better subscribe like oh no it's it's
not like that